local Lillard on NBA to K2 it's a reason  he got that nickname it's simple cause  everybody know what he's shooting that  thing from bro got crazy range look  that's one dribble inside the half court  line but I wanted to see if I could  bring logo Lillard to 2K you know at the  start of calm it's not that far from the  three-point line and I was feeling  myself I said let me back up a little  bit green here's what I knew I had it I  know y'all see me at that logo then I  went to the right side of the court to  see if I could still hit from that side  easy enough greens this to play when I  knew I was him one step over half court  give me that logo leather